Louis from Florida hey Lewis welcome to
the show hey are you doing I'm doing
well how are you comfortable
good yes yep I can hear you what's up
okay great well um well this is my home
I'm calling in because Lee sneezes got
married in July
my wife is expecting and actually has
yeah I had another kid well we have
another kid he already did some
background information
no that's great that's great okay so
what can I help you with yeah so right
now we have R and F and just wanted to
know how to manage our money better he
had over 100 and about two hundred
thousand dollars in debt for student
loans 1200 1300 and other cards and then
like another nine thousand and other
debts this is like Cardinals lawyer fees
medical expenses okay Louis how much did
you guys make a year our take-home is
around seventy six thousand here take
home and kind of there may be pain and
problems it's like business from fits
from other business extra work and stuff
okay okay so around 90 okay what were
the degrees in to go 200 thousand
dollars in student loan debt
well I'm a chemistry chemistry telephone
or yeah and she's got her degree in
physical education and sports and she is
she working or she home she's working
she's working as well but I'm not
actually working in the field
okay okay so what so what's your
question specifically for me
how can I help you they're just how did
he start getting on the same page is not
verified they argue about we argue about
money a lot yeah like yeah they found me
she says that I'm very aggressive and
I'm bullish about finances yeah well I
just wanted to know about that just how
to get out of it yep absolutely okay so
a couple of things on the relationship
side you guys obviously are not on the
same page when money's talked about I'm
guessing there's a lot of tension a lot
of fighting and a lot of stress because
you guys I mean yeah you're you're in
over your heads and you're feeling these
payments where majority of your income
is going to debt and and it is stressful
and for your wife in her perspective I
can tell you the number one fear for
women when it comes to money is the lack
of security and thank you okay if
something unexpected comes up are we
gonna be okay and that's for a majority
of women not all but most women I talk
to and so she probably Louis I'm gonna
say it has a ton of fear right now she's
probably freaking out because she sees
this pile of debt she and her husband
aren't are not getting along when the
subject is brought up and there's that
tension so I I always tell couples when
you're working together you have to have
empathy you have got to put yourself in
the other person's shoes and she needs
to do that as well with you and so you
both have to understand where where you
are and you need to talk about the
emotional side of money because that's
what motivates us that's the wreath ATS
why we handle money the way we do so you
need to understand how she's feeling and
she needs to understand where you're
coming from and so getting that clear
communication is going to be key and the
best way to do that tactically is to sit
down and you guys need to start working
this plan so my first question for you
is are you guys on a budget a loose
budget or the night we're gonna call
that not a budget but it's around here
zero-based okay so which means your
income coming in monthly you need to
write out all of your expenses and the
key here is for your you're giving your
saving and all of your expenses have to
add up to what you're bringing in each
month so whenever the paycheck comes in
you know exactly where it's designated
you know exactly what category every
single dollar is going and download our
every dollar app if you haven't do that
right now download every dollar and
start working that first budget and you
guys sitting down together
so what usually in a relationship one of
you is a little bit more of like the
nerd who enjoys doing everything is that
more you would you say yes okay so
you're gonna be good at this this is in
your strength and usually people like
this you know and your chemical engineer
I think you said so numbers work for you
so you're gonna be able to lay this out
well and then you're gonna bring her in
and you guys are gonna sit down and talk
about in this first this first meeting
it's gonna be there's gonna be some
tension so just prepare yourself because
it's hard it's hard to look at the
reality of where you're at but once you
get it there then you guys can say okay
this is where we're agreeing on how
we're spending our money so you've got
it that's the first step you guys guys
you gotta get the kid on that same page
and then you're gonna save up for $1,000
emergency funds next and in your budget
your second line item under giving is
saving you've got to be saving something
every single month get that thousand
dollar emergency fund and then your guys
are gonna do the debt snowball which is
where you list all your debts smallest
to largest regardless of the interest
rate pay minimum payments on everything
and pay off that smallest debt first and
so that was a lot of information Liz I
know you guys are you feel like in over
your heads but I'm telling you if you
guys can sit down agree on where the
money's going tactically speaking and
then you start working on paying off
debt together your marriage you guys are
going to unite in a way that you never
thought possible